With 27 features since 2008, the Marvel
Cinematic Universe has given fans some
truly superlative filmgoing experiences.
But which movies are the absolute best?
Which are better off left unwatched in your next
marathon? Keep watching for a complete ranking.
In theory, 2013's The Dark World has everything
you could want. In practice, though, it's just not
very fun. Chris Hemsworth is as charming as ever,
and it’s based in part on one of the greatest
comic book runs of all time. It’s got a Star
Wars-style attack on Asgard by spaceships flown by
dark elves! It has the rock monsters from Thor's
very first comics appearance! Thor and Loki team
up for revenge against the villain that killed
their mom, climaxing in a fistfight in which
Thor and Malekith are literally punching each
other so hard that they land in other dimensions!
Unfortunately, while all of
that sounds good on paper,
it's actually both super
boring and generally confusing.
When Nick Fury showed up at the end of Iron
Man and hinted at the idea of a full-on
shared universe of superhero movies, fans
were thrilled. And then The Incredible
Hulk hit theaters a month later to prove you
should really be careful what you wish for.
It's not that the film is terrible. But it's
something almost worse: forgettable. Which is
a real shame when you consider that it does so
much right. For one thing, if you're going to
make a movie about a nerdy scientist with anger
issues so powerful they could level a whole town,
getting the guy who starred in Fight Club
to play Bruce Banner is a pretty solid move.
For another, the filmmakers realized
audiences didn't need a full-blown
origin story to get up to speed. Tying the
Hulk’s origin into Captain America and the
Super Soldier program was the first
stumbling step towards building the
full-on shared universe. In the end,
though, it just didn't quite land.
Critics praised director Chloe Zhao's "Eternals"
for its inclusivity and ambition, but story-wise,
it didn't live up to the hype.
Unlike the vast majority of MCU
movies, "Eternals" is a little
too much like homework. With more
than a dozen new heroes and villains,
the film feels somehow overstuffed and meandering
at the same time. Despite some big names in front
of and behind the camera, this cosmic epic
turned out undercooked. Discussions over whose
fault that is will likely continue for some
time; the general consensus in the Hollywood
trades was that Oscar winner Zhao was hamstrung
by having to adhere to Marvel's strict formula.
While it teases some exciting
future projects "Eternals"
on its own is a convoluted mess that ranks
embarrassingly low in the MCU standings.
"You are so pathetic!"
Sam Rockwell literally dancing across the stage to
present his army of Iron Man drones is endlessly
delightful, but there's a lot in this movie that
doesn't involve Justin Hammer busting a move,
and that's where it fails to measure up. Hammer
and Whiplash both serve as evil versions of Tony
Stark, bringing unnecessary complications to
the story. Even worse, the scene when Stark
goes down into his basement with a particle
accelerator to somehow build a new element
might be the goofiest thing in the entire MCU, and
those movies have a talking raccoon from space.
At the same time, Iron Man 2
was a confident stride towards
the full MCU, introducing the
Black Widow and War Machine,
and even teasing Thor's arrival in the
next film. There's a lot there to like,
and even if it's outweighed by the bad stuff,
we'll always have Justin Hammer's dance moves.
Iron Man 2 might've been the first big step
towards fleshing out the Marvel Universe, but
Thor was the first time we actually
got to see its scope in action.
With Thor we got Asgard in all its glory, complete
with a rainbow laser bridge, epic battles against
frost giants, and—perhaps most importantly—those
big ol' Jack Kirby hats that Norse gods apparently
love to wear. It even gave us a viking
god robot with a face made of death
lasers. And it introduced arguably the
best villain in the whole MCU, Loki.
Like Thor: The Dark World, though, the original
Thor film somehow ended up feeling like less
than the sum of its parts. It should have
been great, but ended up merely... okay.
Iron Man 3 tried to do something different,
and it succeeded brilliantly. Unfortunately,
what it was trying to do was defy expectations
by completely undermining everything
fans loved about Iron Man and the MCU.
Iron Man 3 explores how the smartest guy in the
room deals with living in a world that's becoming
something that he can't predict. It's a movie
about a superhero with an anxiety disorder,
which results in Iron Man spending the
entire movie not wanting to be Iron Man,
and thus being Iron Man as little as possible.
Plus, there was the whole fake Mandarin thing,
which some people loved... but most fans
were either confused or disappointed by.
Director Shane Black deserves
credit for his bold vision,
which made for a good movie -
just not a good Marvel movie.
When 2016's Doctor Strange was announced, the big
question for comics fans was how the mind-bending
psychedelic sorcery of the mystical Marvel
Universe was going to fit into the MCU.
As comics fans know, things get pretty weird.
*psychedelic freakout*
And from a visual standpoint,
the filmmakers absolutely
nailed it. The splitting realities in the
movie's fight scenes were beautifully weird,
and the ghostly ethereal plane where
life-and-death battles for the fate of the
Earth could rage unseen was great for showing
how different Stephen Strange's world was.
From a story standpoint, though, it seemed a
little too familiar, as the story beats were
basically Iron Man with magic. Still, you
can do worse than copying one of the most
popular superhero films ever, and
the fantastic climax, with Strange's
time-bending bargain with Dormammu, is one
of the best finales in the MCU to date.
Juggling a massive cast of superheroes is
a difficult task, and while Avengers: Age
of Ultron doesn't manage it quite as well as the
other three Avengers films - or Captain America:
Civil War - it does a pretty good job of balancing
character bits with all-out action. Sure, some
parts seem half baked, like Tony Stark apparently
forgetting every lesson he learned in Iron Man 3,
and Thor's weird spirit quest. But
it boasts a great final battle,
not to mention the introduction of fan favorite
characters Vision and the Scarlet Witch.
Avengers: Age of Ultron isn't perfect,
but it still packs in a lot of fun.
All the way back in 2010, producer Kevin Feige
confirmed that a solo outing for Natasha Romanoff
was in the pipeline, but over a decade would pass
before "Black Widow" hit cineplexes and Disney+.
Taking place right after the events of Captain
America: Civil War, Cate Shortland's prequel sends
Natasha back to Budapest, to deal with her past.
There, she teams up with Yelena Belova, a fellow
Red Room trainee who once posed as Romanoff's
sister, to take down the Black Widow program.
Watching Romanoff right her wrongs after
so many years is undeniably satisfying,
and "Black Widow" benefits from
the fact that it largely stands
alone. It's a gripping watch and a
worthy sendoff for an OG Avenger.
"This thing that you do when you
whip your hair when you're fighting.
With the arm and the hair, and
you do like a fighting pose."
The first Guardians of the Galaxy movie
proved that the MCU could get weird and
cosmic and still be incredibly entertaining.
The second one proved that it wasn't a fluke.
If anything, it went bigger. The first movie
brought us stuff like the Nova Corps and Ronan
the Accuser, but Vol. 2 has about a half hour
of superheroes battling Ego the Living Planet.
It's got waves of space drones
swarming into starship battles,
a warp drive sequence that knows exactly how
silly it is, and it features the best Stan Lee
cameo in cinema history and the single
best use of a Zune in anything, ever.
It's tempting to say Ant-Man shouldn't
have worked as well as it did, and
that a second-tier superhero with
the ability to get really tiny and
talk to ants was a big surprise when it started to
rake in hundreds of millions of dollars. Really,
though, it's not that unexpected. After
all, Marvel's first big movie success
came from a pretty obscure D-Lister
from the pages of Tomb of Dracula.
Audiences have always been interested in stories
that twist the expected superhero plot points
around into something new, and that's where
Ant-Man really delivers. As easy as it would've
been to portray Scott Lang as a microscopic
version of Iron Man, his story felt different.
"Hey, are we the good guys?"
"Yeah.”
"We’re the good guys, right?"
"Yeah, we’re the good guys."
"Feels kinda weird, ya know?"
The movie has its missteps, like going out of
its way to justify not having the Wasp show up
until the sequel, but on the other hand,
this is a movie in which the hero loses
a fight with a toy train, and Chekhov's
Gun is actually Chekhov's 60-Ton Tank.
That The Avengers works at
all is pretty impressive,
but that it works as well as it
did? That's basically a miracle.
Even less than a decade later, it's difficult
to remember that this was the first time that
anything like this had been attempted: a movie
that combined characters who had been established
in their own films, each with their own tone and
style. In bringing them together, Joss Whedon
had to balance the fantasy of Thor, the snarky
sci-fi of Iron Man, and the sincere superheroics
of Captain America, combining them all—along
with Hulk, Hawkeye, and Black Widow—with stakes
that were high enough to bring everyone together
for a single adventure. And this movie does it.
Those big stakes mostly result from
an army of faceless aliens, but
even that paid off years later in Avengers:
Infinity War. And, Loki getting Hulk-Smashed
like a Looney Tunes character was the
most fun superhero movies had ever been.
It's safe to say Iron Man surprised us all.
It's not that we expected it to be bad.
Tony Stark's origin story is a pretty
good fit for a Hollywood action movie, it
had a great cast, and while director Jon
Favreau might've been best known for Elf,
that really wasn’t a bad thing. But still,
none of us expected it to be so good that it
would become the foundation of the entire MCU.
To say that it was an exceptionally
powerful launch would be an understatement.
There are times when this feels less
like a "superhero" movie and more
like a popcorn revenge flick where the hero
just happens to have a flying suit of armor,
but it did its job so well that those
shortcomings are easy to forgive.
Every set piece in Ant-Man and the Wasp
plays with the idea of changing size,
from the Wasp running along the blade of a knife
to Ant-Man using a flatbed truck as a scooter.
Through it all, this sequel is genuinely
hilarious. After the relentless downer
of "Avengers: Infinity War," this
lighthearted take on superheroes,
with stakes far more personal than
cosmic, was a welcome tone shift.
"What are you, laughing? Please, can you just…"
"Okay! Okay."
Arguably, the best thing about the MCU is
that it feels like a shared universe in the
same way that the comics do. The knowledge
that "Ant-Man and the Wasp" and "Infinity
War" happen at roughly the same time is maybe
the best expression of that. Thanos is solemnly
searching for the Infinity Stones while Scott
Lang is running through an elementary school in
a hoodie because he got stuck at 3 feet tall. And
it all sets up a heck of a gut punch at the end.
The First Avenger does origin stories better
than most, and a lot of that has to do with
Chris Evans. In a franchise that's full of amazing
casting choices, Evans pulls off the incredible
feat of embodying a square-jawed, relentlessly
earnest product of the military-industrial complex
in a way that makes him impossible not to like.
For all that super-strength, there's a character
whose real super-power is making you believe in
him, and that’s exactly what this movie does.
“I can do this all day.”
As good as it was on its own, it also serves as
the proof-of-concept for the superhero movie as
a period piece, and gave the MCU a history that
went further back than 2008 and Tony Stark’s cave.
The first Guardians of the Galaxy movie
manages to balance so much stuff going
on that you almost don't notice how complicated
it is for all the fun you're having. It’s got a
team of lovable misfits dealing with their own
issues while fighting against a massive threat,
expansive interstellar empires, and
a retro feel supported by a classic
rock soundtrack that doesn't feel like
it's wallowing in the past. All that,
and still tells a story so fun that it
made Rocket Raccoon a household name.
It breaks the formula in every way it can, to
the point where it's a superhero team movie that
ends with a dance-off and the heroes literally
saving the universe with the power of friendship.
"Far From Home" is built around the question
of what this universe looks like without
its first superhero, Tony Stark. There's
a void in the MCU that needs to be filled,
and Spider-Man might just be the one to do
it. That's why Mysterio's plot goes all the
way back to the first "Iron Man" film and
weaves through the entire MCU timeline.
Making it all make sense to cap off another
phase of the MCU was an amazing feat.
All the good Spider-Man stuff is here: Peter
Parker has to wrestle with responsibility and self
doubt, the romance with MJ is heartfelt and sweet,
and there are serious consequences for Spider-Man
always walking around with his mask off. There are
world-shattering surprises and lots of fun special
effects from a special-effects wizard villain.
It's a super fun time at the movie theater.
There were some pretty heavy expectations
for Captain Marvel given that it was the
MCU's first film led by a woman.
Luckily, it succeeded big time.
Rather than falling into the tried and true Iron
Man formula that had been used to introduce so
many other MCU characters, Captain Marvel was a
search for identity. That search took place over
the backdrop of an intergalactic war, with the
title character's potential mostly represented
by the main character glowing with literal cosmic
fire while she punched her way through spaceships.
At times, Captain Marvel may
come off as a little corny, but
that corniness is a result of simply being very
earnest and heartfelt, and at times inspiring.
"My name…is Carol."
Between that, the cosmic action, and lots of
jokes about the '90s, it lived up to the hype.
Everything about The Winter Soldier reinforces
the idea that Captain America is exactly the
guy you want to have the power to
save the world. The notebook full
of pop culture references that he needs to
look up to understand the world around him.
The friendship with Sam Wilson that starts
with bonding over their wartime experience.
The loyalty to his friends that leads him
to risk his own life to save Bucky. He even
gives his opponents one last chance to back out
before he beats up an elevator full of traitors.
All of these pieces add up
to a whole that's incredible,
even before you get to how much of the
movie is based around Steve Rogers just
kicking the living hell out of bad
guys. That stuff's pretty fun, too.
Marvel's ultimate goal with Shang-Chi and
the Legend of the Ten Rings was to repeat
the success of "Black Panther," according
to Deadline. And that plan largely worked,
with critics agreeing it was a solid step
toward better Asian representation in Hollywood.
Shang-Chi doesn't stray very far from Marvel's
tried-and-tested origin story formula, but
it sets itself apart when it comes to action.
Director Destin Daniel Cretton's movie pays
homage to the fight choreography of Jackie
Chan, as well as Chinese martial arts films past
and present. Simu Liu brings the perfect blend
of humility and heroism to the title role,
while Awkwafina, Tony Leung, and Michelle
Yeoh are all on their A-games too.
Add in a couple of unexpected
cameos, and you're onto a winner.
"Wong! Wong! Wong! Wong! Wong! Wong! Wong!"
Even though Steve Rogers and Bucky Barnes
are unquestionably the focus of Civil War,
there's a pretty convincing argument to be
made that this movie should've been called
Avengers: Civil War instead.
It has everyone in it, and they aren't
just cameos, either. Ant-Man, Hawkeye,
Scarlet Witch and War Machine all get
huge, character-developing moments
in the middle of a superheroic Royal
Rumble, while the Avengers are split
by a villain who wound up getting exactly
what he wanted. And if that wasn't enough,
it's also the movie that introduced movie
audiences to Black Panther and Spider-Man.
The characters are never flattened out to
fit, and the three-way fight at the end has
not only some of the best action in the MCU,
but some of the most emotional moments, too.
After his debut in Civil War,
T’Challa’s first solo movie came
with some pretty high expectations.
Not only did it live up to them, it blew right
past them for one of the MCU’s best movies.
Maybe it's because Chadwick Boseman's
T'Challa is a character struggling with
the weight of expectations himself. Black
Panther is more than up to the challenge,
but the journey he takes to get there
is full of compelling complications,
from the reveal that his father wasn’t the
flawlessly honorable man that he thought,
to an enemy with some very justifiable
anger at the world around him. It’s a
superhero struggle that goes far beyond
just the punch-out battle in the climax.
Black Panther never shies away from
its high-tech comic book roots,
but tells a story that's very much rooted
in the real world, and does it beautifully.
More than any other superhero movie,
Infinity War captures the feeling of
an epic comic book crossover. There are multiple
interconnected stories going on at the same time,
each with its own flavor, bridging
different story arcs and making sure
every single character gets a moment in the
spotlight. When it comes together at the end,
it’s a fight across multiple planets where the
unbelievably high stakes become very real for
both the characters and the fans who have been
invested in these movies for a full ten years.
That’s a tough enough bit of storytelling
to pull off well even in comic books,
and they’ve had decades of practice. Seeing
it done here, in a single movie that still
has the feeling of encompassing a whole
universe? No other movie has ever done that,
and it’s hard to imagine
another one doing it this well.
As good as it is on its own, the fact
that Peter Parker swings into action after
15 other movies means we don't have
to waste time with an origin story.
Thematically, Homecoming builds on everything
that came before in a truly incredible way,
with direct callbacks to Tony Stark's character
arc that show how different Peter is from the
hero he's trying to impress. The idea
of a superhero universe erupting around
otherwise normal people is the conflict
that drives everything about the movie.
Take that away and you've
still got great characters,
great action, and one of the best scenes in the
franchise. With it, though, you've got pure magic.
To say that Ragnarok lifts heavily from Walt
Simonson's epic mid-'80s run of The Mighty Thor is
putting it mildly. The only things in this
movie that weren't directly inspired by
Simonson are the pieces it pulls directly from
Marvel's more recent Planet Hulk storyline,
right down to the Hulk's gladiator gear. The
thing is, Taika Waititi's film chops up all
those pieces and rearranges them into something
that’s both different and genuinely hilarious.
That part isn't surprising, considering
that before Ragnarok, Waititi was probably
best known for co-directing the vampire
mockumentary What We Do in the Shadows,
but it takes advantage of Chris Hemsworth's
infuriatingly good comedic timing.
"Ow."
"Just had to be sure."
Three generations of Spider-Man movies collide
spectacularly in Spider-Man: No Way Home.
Tom Holland's Peter Parker is
once again the main focus, but
"No Way Home" is closer to an Avengers-style
team-up than the two films that precede it.
Doctor Strange plays a huge role, but some
characters from outside the MCU show up, too.
In what was one of the worst-kept
secrets in MCU history, Tobey Maguire
and Andrew Garfield appear to offer Holland's
Peter Parker sage advice and much-needed comfort
in the fight to save the lives of the villains
from those two actors' own Spider-Man flicks.
Holland finally gets his "With great
power comes great responsibility" moment,
and it's one that you won't forget. The Brit turns
in his most accomplished performance as Spidey,
backed up by the all-star supporting cast. No
Way Home is the best Spider-Man movie to date.
Endgame could have gone wrong really
easily. It's meant to serve as the
climax of the 21 movies before
it in the first saga of the MCU,
so saying that Marvel pulled it off is saying
that they pretty much achieved a miracle.
The film is loaded with callbacks
in ways that you don't even
realize until you stop to think about
them: Captain America's support group,
New Asgard, Black Widow wiping out the red in her
ledger, and the list goes on. It's payoff after
payoff, but it never feels like pure fan
service. It really does feel like an ending.
Plus, Endgame has plenty of great moments
on its own. The time-travel hijinks,
the debut of Professor Hulk, the audacity
of skipping ahead five years, and the sheer
fist-pumping awesomeness of Cap tightening up his
shield and standing alone against the apocalypse.
It really is the thundering climax
fans have wanted from the start.
"Is that everyone?"
"What, you wanted more?"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU are
coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.